if we could just linger on the on the
drake equation
for a little bit we kind of talked about
there's a lot of uncertainty in the
parameters
and and our and in the direct equation
itself is very limited
but i think the parameters are
interesting in themselves
even if it's limited because i think
each one is within the reach of science
right right did you get the evidence for
uh i mean
one a few i find really interesting
could be
interesting to get your comment on uh so
the one with the most
variance i i would say from my
perspective is the
length that civilizations last however
you define it and the drake equation is
the length of how long you're
communicating yeah just like
transmitting just like you said that
that might that's a
wrong way to think about it because we
could be detecting some other outputs of
the civilizations etc
but just if we just define broadly how
long those civilizations last
do you have a sense of uh how long
that might last like what what are the
great filters that might destroy
civilizations that we should be thinking
about
what uh yeah is in and what it how can
science give us more hints
on this topic so uh i as i mentioned
before
operate by the copernican principle
meaning that
you know we are not special we don't
live in a special place
and not in a special time and by the way
it's
just modesty encapsulated in scientific
terms
yes right you're saying i'm not special
you know i find conditions here
they exist everywhere yes so if you
adopt the copernican principle
you basically say our civilization
transmitted radio signals for
100 years roughly
so probably it would last another 100 or
a few hundred and that's it
because we don't live at a special time
so that's
you know well of course if we get our
act together
and we somehow start to cooperate rather
than fighting each other
killing each other you know wasting a
lot of resources
on things that would destroy our planet
maybe we can lengthen that period if we
get smarter
but the the most natural assumption is
to say
that we would live into the future as
much as we lived
from the time that we start to develop
the means for our own destruction the
technologies we have
which is quite pessimistic i must say so
several centuries that's what i would
give
not unless we get our act unless we
become more intelligent
than the newspapers report every day
you